ok do you know why I'm under arrest sir
why why am i under arrest
CNN reporter Omar Jimenez was arrested
live on air Friday morning he was just
taken in to police custody live on
television Omar was reporting a live
segment in Minneapolis for the network's
show new day which was covering the
protests that broke out in the city as a
result of George Floyd's death earlier
this week George and African American
man living in Minnesota died after a
police officer held him down by the neck
with his knee for more than seven
minutes when he was arrested for
suspicion of forgery outside of a deli
this is among the state patrol unit that
was advancing up the street in the video
of Omar's report tons of police officers
in riot gear can be seen behind him then
some officers tackle a person to the
ground before approaching Omar and his
crew this is the four of us we are one
team just put us put us back where you
want us we were getting out of your way
so just let us know wherever you'd want
us we will we will go we were just
getting out of your way when you're
advancing through the intersection so
just let us know and we got you and this
is a scene here playing out in
Minneapolis Omar kept it calm and kept
reporting and if you look closely you
can see the officer holding on to his
arm this is among the state patrol unit
that was advancing up the street
saying and scattering the protesters at
that point for people to clear the area
that's when things shifted and the CNN
correspondent ended up in cuffs Wyatt
why am i under arrest
okay if you're just tuning in you are
watching our correspondent Omar Jimenez
being arrested by State Police in
Minnesota we're not sure why our
correspondent is being arrested after
Omar was taken away in handcuffs his
news crew was also arrested on camera in
handcuffs I've never seen anything like
this
neither Omar nor his crew were given a
reason for their arrests but the cameras
kept rolling even after they were taken
away yeah this is the police carrying
our camera right now frankly not aware
that it's still rolling following the
arrest fellow CNN reporter Abbey Philip
tweeted that CNN president Jeff Zucker
spoke to Minnesota governor Tim Walz who
apologized for the incident ABI tweeted
quote he is working to get them released
adding walls said he takes full
responsibility for what happened
well everyone to their credit was pretty
cordial after that happened
Omar went back on air following his
release and explained that they were
arrested after they moved their position
to get out of the way of the police
there was no animosity there they
weren't they weren't violent with me we
were having conversation about just how
crazy this week has been for every
single part of the city and like I
mentioned a lot of these people are on
edge Omar added that he and his crew
continued to identify themselves to
police as they were handcuffed in a van
before their belongings were returned
and they were allowed to leave that gave
me a little bit of comfort knowing that
you guys saw what was happening I was
living what was happening and the
country was seeing what was happening
unfold in real time right before their
eyes you don't have to doubt my story
it's not filtered in any sort of way you
saw it for your own eyes and that gave
me a little bit of compass but it
definitely was nerve-racking at certain
points
[Music]